you cut your hair since I last saw it I
shaved my head bald and then because I
wanted to donate it and I was always
shave my head and then I did it on the
stage because I thought it'd be funny
and I think
nothing compares to you
you're saying nothing compares to as you
shaved your head yeah yeah and then
donated the hair yeah okay correct and
how long did it take to get back to uh
oh it grew back but it became afro so I
cut it again
um okay yeah were you are you worried at
all about I mean you're a an actor are
you worried about getting work or
getting it hired after you shave your
head not really I don't really think I'm
an actor I have a very limited range
[Laughter]
what's the most honest thing anyone's
ever said and I talked to it I have very
limited range
well I've seen I mean I thought you were
amazing and knocked up but I I I so I
yeah I would think of you as an actress
yeah I guess
I definitely auditioned that much
um and I think after knocked up it's
funny I got offered some roles and I
usually just perform live stuff but I
met with this uh these people I don't
want to say about sitcom who it has a
very popular sitcom they're like we want
to ride apart for you we love you
knocked up you know and I was like oh
yeah as long as I get to have input and
um I could like improvise because I'm
not really good at reading lines I sound
like I'm reading and then a month passes
and I get a phone call and they're like
we need to do tomorrow for table read
and I'm like oh God what am I gonna do
they're gonna realize how bad I suck and
I'm like like I took some phonics I
can't process things
and I'm there at the table read and I
don't understand like people like their
show but I don't understand their humor
and so we're surrounded by people who
are reading and everyone's laughing like
and then quiet like canned laughter and
I was terrified and I called my agent
I'm like I don't understand the humor in
this can I get out of this and she's
like no you signed a contract I'm like
oh my God my soul's dying
um
do you remember any of the lines yeah um
the next day we had to just recite it on
the same day we had to recite it as if
we knew the lines I don't know how to do
that so one of my lines was don't bother
me right now I'm using this hydraulic
laser beam to heat up this cup of noodle
and the director's like really yell cup
of noodle because that's the punch line
and I'm like okay
um don't bother me right now because I'm
using this hydraulic laser beam to heat
up this couple noodle
um
I don't know no one laughs
and the next day we get to uh do it in
front of the producers I was like oh God
I'm so nervous and they're like don't
worry it's not like you're gonna get
fired and that day I'm driving home my
agent calls me she goes guess what I go
what she goes you got fired I'm like yes
[Applause]
um what about do you uh okay that was a
television show what about movies do you
audition for movies have you auditioned
for anything that we would know like any
famous movies yeah
this movie hasn't come out yet um screen
for
I what did you audition for in a Scream
movie The Killer because I thought it'd
be funny
[Applause]
I'm sorry you auditioned for the role of
the killer in a Scream movie yeah why on
Earth would you do that that is that's
just
um I thought maybe I could audition
stuff and uh record and get all the
audition tips and show it to people oh
because you're so not you're not really
what someone would see is the killer I
don't know I am
um
how about now
I actually took off my glasses during
the audition and they're like what are
you doing I was like I'm trying to look
more intimidating
um I was like you guys ready and I like
based off the first script the line was
like
there's a ringing people just bring
phones into our show yeah just please
turn that off oh my God it's TBS
whatever uh
um oh but the line was uh the killer
line was um what's the matter Sid you
scared
and uh did that scare you I can't see
I saw you jump backwards that's not
something a killer says did I did
actually I'm having trouble let me get
my
oh frightened